Miley Cyrus emotional over hurricane
Harvey plus Korean and Demario together
again hey friends and welcome back to
the daily deni by now we've seen the
devastation hurricane Harvey has caused
on the folks in Texas and today an
outpouring of love support and financial
aid continues from Hollywood to Houston
to aid relief efforts among the stars
stepping up is Miley Cyrus who has
clearly overcome with emotion sitting
down with Ellen people no I'm not eating
like I couldn't fake it I just like is
just you know my grandma's sitting here
and my mom's here and I go home to my
seven dogs and if I didn't have that
anymore it's really hard so I'm really
happy to help any way that I can and I
hope people understand Miley donated a
half a million dollars to relief efforts
meanwhile Leonardo DiCaprio doubled that
giving a million dollars through his
Charitable Foundation also a week from
Tuesday it appears there will be a
star-studded primetime telethon with
Texan Jamie Foxx Michael Strahan Blake
Shelton and Hilary Duff will reportedly
host it meanwhile a herd of a listers
were out in full force on GMA for
Disney's Day of Giving including a rod
who was answering phones of course he
and his girlfriend JLo each donated
$25,000 to the Red Cross giving back
even if it's five cents amazing how much
Hollywood is pitching in but we are
switching gears now to zendaya who was
dishing out some relationship advice the
20 year old took to her app to answer
some fan questions where she revealed
that she's been cheated on wise beyond
her years here's was in day learned from
that experience you feel it it's
probably happening if you feel like you
can't trust somebody or you feel
whatever then you shouldn't be in a
relationship with them you don't trust
them completely is that relationship is
to again that's why I'm so like anti
being in a committed relationship when
you're young and people are learning and
growing and stuff because when people
are young they make bad decisions
sometimes because they don't know any
better because I haven't lived enough
life to know what's you know doesn't
mean they don't know the difference room
right and wrong it just means that
there's still an experimental phase in
their life where they just haven't made
the right decision yet so I would say
you know that's something I learned is
you know it's very hard to be in a
relationship when the both of you are
still figuring out life you better
freaks in death you know she also says
you can't make someone grow up any
faster than they're supposed to in fact
the Disney star actually turns 21
tomorrow but as I found out it seems
she's in no hurry to find a man have you
found that it's hard to date Hollywood
have such a young age it doesn't matter
you know where you are either I mean
it's it's hard to date in general you
know sometimes it's hard to you know
find people that you really click with
or really understand you and add on top
of the fact that my lifestyle is very
different so I mean it's this tough but
she's chilling now but India is on the
brink of a massive career so girl you
got plenty of time to date collect your
coin first okay all right how's this for
a little shock and awe Karenin Demario
reunited last night since the bachelor
in paradise scandal and clearly they
have put that all behind them check this
out they were spotted hanging out last
night for dinner and a source tells us
they looked very relaxed together acting
like old friends but by the looks of it
they were real relaxed as
Krynn wrapped her legs around to Mario
now our lauren zima was with korean
today and check out what she had to say
about their little late-night reunion we
saw some pictures last night you and do
mario hung out yeah what was that like
to see him it's great I mean there was
never any bad feelings between us which
I had said many times so I'm really glad
we got to hang out finally and just like
be our normal selves we're just having a
good time was that the first time you
guys have seen each other last night yes
Wow
so I got to ask you do you guys like
hugging each other I mean you guys both
have big personalities are you mugging
for the cameras a little bit they're
like just lie mean yeah we've got that
big personality so we kind of he they
were like oh yeah hug each other and I
just jumped on him you know we're just
were just friendly like that so I think
he said Corinne text me and this
paparazzi video he says Korean text me
or you get home did you text him I did
you did I did so things are good yeah
we're great is there still any
attraction there I mean he's a
good-looking guy but um I don't know if
that'll ever turn into anything but yeah
I mean birches friends we're just moving
on past the drama Corinne tells us that
there is also no bad feelings with a VC
and since she's recently single could
she pop back up as the Bachelorette
Corinne says anything is possible
all right only time will tell but let's
get through paradise first huh all right
check back with us tomorrow to see what
tracks made it onto our new music Friday
playlist and hit subscribe so you don't
miss it
until then head over to ET online.com to
find out how stars are pitching in to
help hurricane Harvey relief efforts bye
for now